hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to riddle school now this
game is an oddity and I have to explain
why a lot of you guys have been
recommending this game so I had to look
it up and I found out that this game
first came out on Newgrounds 10 years
ago and that may not seem amazing but 10
years ago was my primary time for
trolling around new grounds and playing
all the games and the thing is this is a
very popular game on Newgrounds and i've
never heard of it i've never even seen
it i've never played a single game and
that's like eight games in the series
admittedly they came out over time but
why didn't I find out about it so I had
to look up the developer and his name is
John Breaux on Newgrounds but in new
grounds on a post he made he said he's
no longer going by the name of John
Breaux he's going by the name of John
Akram so that name sounded familiar and
here's why when I looked up John Akram I
found out that he is the developer of
one night at flumpty's
which is by far my favorite fan game of
five nights at freddys so it's a weird
circle of events that really is not
really coincidence it's it's just
spawned from a neato idea you know a
factoid a factoid
[ __ ] it let's play the game anyway okay
whoa
wait that's that's the madness
soundtrack is that a reference to that
when it says math miss cuz that's that's
madness music I definitely know that
from the madness games if you don't know
about the madness flash animations not
games go look him up there are new
grounds they're all amazing if you like
bloody violent gory stick figure type
people blasting each other with guns you
might want to check out a lot of cool
flash movies about that one but anyway
girl I've been sitting here for two
straight hours listening to addition
facts all because I tease somebody I'm
in a special class I don't even have a
smart teacher right now I'm as free as a
bird in a bird cage alright that's it
I'm getting out of the school
why hundred thirty one plus forty two
again I forget uh 173 oh god he died
oh well riddle school yeah
oh okay I guess we're playing now hello
South the teacher maybe not be smart but
he knows when I open that door oh no
outlet here you can tell the school's
low budget just by looking at that okay
all right then that's it
what's it hey teacher could I sharpen my
pencil only one person at a time
wow you are a bright person oh oh now
that was sure Oh God is this gonna be a
pong game I make enough puns in the
titles of my other games but this is
ridiculous all right water fountain
lockers north oh hi oh hey teacher this
is my teacher miss coffee she who drinks
more coffee than anyone else I know she
finishes teaching lessons two hours
early and a hard to understand jittery
voice that's smiley she's the only one
in school who likes learning Smiley's
also one I made fun of to be in that
special class that's Fred my best friend
and most bored class member that's that
who's always cold he has no problem
freezing the water fountain okay that's
probably a clue oh wow feather Buster in
the blue toilet that's a drawing by
somebody named John Breaux who's a
developer this game okay so that's
probably a clue because I'm probably
gonna need to freeze that water fountain
for some frickin reason I have no idea
why you don't want to know what's a
venire I think I do north hello why are
you standing in a closet Bob and why is
your name tag on password get out of my
closet okay that's really weird maybe I
need to dust off everything oh hey
everything was dusty that's what I did
there you found my feather duster keep
the change okay thanks I've been looking
all over the school for this the
playground birds need dusting
well I gave you a dollar don't waste it
on socks what he's a janitor he's five
sad 8:08 okay all righty then okay I'm
already confused but here we go
I heart nobody five was not here or nee
are my fav color okay that's the only
stall the guy's ever used mainly for
graffiti
that's the untouched stall which is in
perfect condition and currently on
display as crazy as it sounds so the
sinks just look at the sleek design I
would have thought twice about escaping
cool if it was all that cool looking
okay Louise
hey it's me Richie the tall guard you
got a Hall Pass cuz if you don't you
can't pass okay so I need to go find a
Hall Pass maybe miss coffee can she give
me a Hall Pass yeah okay so I gotta find
a ho I didn't even mean to click on that
is the other lockers have anything in
them probably not
5 4 pres 5 is a popular guy in this
school it's because of his vote 5 shirt
oh I get that reference okay so I got a
Hall Pass yeah I got a Hall Pass
get out my way listen if I went in there
you'd hear screaming and shrieks not
only from anyone in there but from me
school has seven students in more than
50 lockers that's a poster I made
because of the bizarre number of lockers
okay all right oh hi what the hell are
you doing Oh give me a cookie I don't
have a cookie I got a dollar whoa what
happened to him
bet he died for it what the hell
happened okay
what are you doing in here I don't know
what's with this office geez I need to
talk to the principal standing what a
teacher are you wrong room what Oh what
teacher are you that's none of your
business get out okay you talk to the
principal and why is that I want to tell
him a joke
no jokes are always fun go right in what
why is my weird logic making me progress
through this game that doesn't make any
sense
I'll take it whatever it's fine by me oh
hi
this is definitely madness music a
hundred percent and I love it hi oh
sorry everybody
Wow what kind of principle are you
asking you to drop by
by then thanks lady you're so nice
okay alright so Wow holy [ __ ] what is
this Akitas key to outside whoo
hello that's Greg the least hungry and
most restful student in the school
that's a diagram of the cafeteria coke
vending machine is unfortunately broken
they used alien air now at school famous
smiley smudge that's how I made fun of
smiley with mustard okay school famous
huh all right so we gotta get through
this door somehow which means that we
got to get stuff to get through the door
which means that we need to find
something else but I can't go there I've
been in the bathroom gonna see so
there's got to be like a locked door oh
okay Wow was that it holy crap it was
inspired by pecos school okay
I thought it was a little vaguely
familiar and I have played Pico school
okay if you don't know about new grounds
their mascot is a guy by the name of
Pico and there still is Pico day and
then people would make animations about
it in the creator of new grounds Tom
fault would make animations about Pico
as a whole eco surround the new grounds
is its own living Beast and you know it
may have fallen out of popularity but it
still holds a very keen place in my
heart and I'm shocked that that's the
end of the game I don't know if there
was some other secret that I was
supposed to do there I mean what was the
whole point about the kid freeze in the
water I mean there's a lot more riddle
school games apparently there's like
eight of them in total or something like
that and they all expand periods of time
and I'm curious to play them because I
relate very much to new grounds and all
of these like references to different
new ground sinks that are in here and
it's really cool to see
but either way I'll leave that up to you
if you want to see the other games let
me know down in the comments below I
always love going through and seeing all
the cool news great
stuff that is out there so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
oh my god